pétrole mais mon bar fin d'un désastre
il met en garde producteurs et
consommateurs iran l'ambassade
américaine toujours occupée jimmy carter
arrête les importations de pétrole
iranien bavure à orléans un ordinateur
se trompent
un policier tire un jeune homme
grièvement blessé messieurs bonsoir
encore et toujours le pétrole en tête
des nouvelles de ce lundi 12 le pétrole
parce qu'il semble que le plus gros
producteur le plus gros tort
exportateurs en tout cas l'arabie
saoudite puissant n'augmenter puisse en
augmenter le prix sans même attendre la
prochaine conférence de l'opep le mois
prochain à caracas
les saoudiens sont je vous le rappelle
les principaux fournisseurs de la france
et c'est peut-être ce qui a conduit le
premier ministre à faire ce matin un
appel à la responsabilité des
producteurs et des consommateurs
sinon dit-il nous allons au désastre
consommateurs ne manifeste pas dans les
circonstances actuelles un exceptionnel
esprit de responsabilité
le monde et je pèse mes bourg le monde
peut s'acheminer vers un désastre pour
la france nous avons choisi la voie de
la responsabilité
nous devons d'abord développer au
maximum les ressources louve premier
rang de ressources nationales se trouve
l'électricité nucléaire
elle est non seulement très compétitive
mais elle est surtout la seule à pouvoir
vraiment modifier la structure notre
notre bilan énergétique en moins de 10
la politique électro nucléaire de la
france est une priorité nationale le
gouvernement la conduira sans hésitation
ni défaillance mais nous avons la
volonté d'accompagner son programme un
effort systématique pour assurer la
mobilisation de toutes mes ressources
nationales possible relance de
l'exploration pétrolière
autre territoire mise en valeur de nos
ressources hydrauliques va encore
équipés nouvelles utilisations possibles
du charbon notamment dans l'industrie et
raymond barre de vente également les
énergies nouvelles alors philippe
patient peut considérer qu'il s'agit de
milan garde assez solennel tous les
premières à comprendre il faut rappeler
quelles sont les grandes
caractéristiques actuellement du marché
pétrolier d'abord tous les pays
producteurs ce livre depuis plusieurs
semaines de hausse des prix les français
par exemple ont payé en octobre leur
pétrole 4 % plus cher et cela signifie
que probablement dans le courant du mois
de décembre et bien il y aurait une
répercussion au niveau des prix du
carburant ensuite un certain nombre de
producteurs de pétrole ont déjà diminué
leur production menacent de le faire
pendant l'année 1981 cela signifie que
les pays producteurs préfèrent avoir du
pétrole dans le sable du désert plutôt
que des dollars dans des banques
enfin les producteurs sont de plus en
plus poussés à vendre directement sur
les marchés que l'on appelle libre leur
pétrole et où les prix sont beaucoup
plus élevés et cette vente directe en
quelque sorte favorise la flambée des
cours du pétrole alors qu'est ce qu'a
voulu dire monsieur raymond barre et
bien en ce qui concerne les producteurs
concile constat qu'il est une véritable
anarchie
sur les marchés pétroliers en ce qui
concerne les consommateurs à tokyo lors
du sommet international du mois de juin
dernier les consommateurs les
consommateurs occidentaux s'étaient
engagés à freiner leur consommation de
pétrole
or actuellement il semble que certains
pays le premier ministre ne les a pas
nommés il s'agit semble-t-il du japon et
de l'allemagne ne jouent pas le jeu et
qu'actuellement
eh bien il est un petit peu une de trop
fort à achat sur ces marchés pétroliers
le premier ministre donc voulu dire que
si s'énerve cette anarchie persister
l'année 1980 sur une année très
difficile mais que cette anarchie
pouvait avoir des conséquences qui
pourraient dépasser les conséquences
économiques
deuxième gros producteurs d'or noir
l'iran et ce sans doute l'une des
raisons pour lesquelles parfois
égoïstement s'y intéressent tant
l'épreuve de force se poursuit ce soir
plus tendue que jamais entre washington
et téhéran
à tel point qu'il y à une demi heure
nous apprenions que jimmy carter décidé
d'interdire purement et simplement
l'exportation de pétrole iranien aux
états unis réaction immédiate de jacques
sic
le président américain annonce que moi
même je préfère la consommation du
pétrole obtenu par l'importation
cette réaction pour l'école publique
point de départ de cette irritation
cette centaine d'otages qui sont
toujours détenus à l'ambassade
américaine sans que leur situation est
évolué d'un pouce aujourd'hui à téhéran
conséquence les américaines nous l'avons
vu avec la réaction jimmy carter sont de
plus en plus remontés contre les
iraniens et manifestent leur réprobation
parfois même à ce avec violence ainsi un
étudiant américain at il été tué à
danvers l'occasion de l'une de ces
manifestations
les atr en neuf jours après le début de
la prise d'otages l'avenue qui longe
l'ambassade américaine est toujours le
théâtre d'un incroyable déchaînement
populaire ici celle effigie du président
des états unis pendu à une potence que
la foule fait brûler par delà ce
simulacre c'est une fois de plus envers
le chapeau s'exprime la violence de la
rue jusqu'aux militaires qui ont
aujourd'hui manifester au milieu de la
foule eux aussi désire voir le souverain
déchu comparaître devant la justice du
nouveau régime et répondre de
l'exécution si le règne du shah de
plusieurs de leurs compagnons barque
c'est de ce procès que chacun parle en
iran comme il y en a des ordres
diplomatique indescriptible au centre
des préoccupations le sort des 60 otages
de l'ambassade des etats-unis au caire
l'envoyé spécial du pape a rendu
hier aucune proposition de médiation n'a
encore fait son chemin
en revanche est dans l'incertitude
actuelle le gouvernement allemand vient
d'inviter ceux de ses 2500 retour
ressortissants en iran dont la présence
n'est pas indispensable à prendre leurs
dispositions pour quitter le pays
pour bones à l'heure actuelle il ne
s'agit pas encore d'évacuation générale
mais l'on préfère que la plupart des
citoyens allemands qui vivent
actuellement l'iran rentrer le plus vite
possible en allemagne fédérale
on pense en effet que ses ingénieurs
techniciens et autres hommes d'affaires
allemands qui travaillent pour des
firmes comme next mercedes ou siemens ne
sont pas tout à fait en sécurité dans un
pays où l'antiaméricanisme ambiant
risque de s'étendre et c'est l'analyse
que l'on fait ici à d'autres nations
européennes et notamment à l'allemagne
fédérale
un pays dans les relations privilégiées
avec les états unis sont notoires dans
le monde entier et singulièrement en
iran cela d'autant plus que les
allemands occupent la deuxième place
dans l'est que de me ryan tout de suite
après les états unis et que le chat
avait en son temps vous en souvenez
peut-être investi une partie de ses
pétrodollars en allemagne fédérale et
notamment chez krupp
alors partant de tout cela on préfère
être prudent prendre des précautions
dans la tente de compulsion d'évolution
révolutionnaire tout à fait imprévisible
en iran en revanche à paris pas
d'inquiétude au quai d'orsay pas
question au moins pour le moment pour le
ministère des affaires étrangères de
faire rapatrier les ressortissants
français en iran autres prolongements ça
va faire la prise de position du parti
communiste français disent patin dans
l'humanité approuvé la demande des
étudiants iraniens demande d'extradition
du chat mais alors a demandé jean michel
mercurol n'est ce pas approuvé le
principe des prises d'otages
réponse de pierre juquin nous avons
toujours condamné les prises d'otages
les tribunaux d'exception tout ce qui
porte atteinte aux droits de l'homme
nous défendons les droits de l'homme et
les libertés individuelles et publiques
partout dans le monde
cela dit il faut aller au fond des
choses pour l'iran non sûrs leurs
contrats avec les loups en iran le chat
était un véritable hitler il a fait
fusiller torturé pendant des années des
années
dizaines de milliers de ses concitoyens
il a livré son pays aux compagnies
pétrolières américaines
il a affamé et a servi son peuple
aujourd'hui je vois dans ce qui se passe
en iran sous des formes qui ne sont pas
celles de nos peuples de nos régions de
nos cultures une révolte profond pour
l'indépendance nationale pour la liberté
pour le droit de vivre des iraniens
alors il faut trouver une solution
positive qui sauve la vie des otages
mais qui permettent que l'on fasse
comparaître le chat comme denis terrien
dans devant l'opinion internationale
dans une sorte de procès de nuremberg
mais la prise d'otages c'est quand même
une violence d'état voulait dénoncer
ailleurs et vous l'acceptez là je viens
de dire que nous ne sommes pas partisans
de ce genre de méthode mais il ne faut
pas condamner trop vite ce qui se passe
nous proposons une solution positive
compte tenu des réalités
on ne peut pas demander à ce peuple qui
a tellement souffert car on a tellement
subi ou des dizaines de milliers de gens
pour une fois on était torturé et
massacré de réagir de façon simplement
pacifique aujourd'hui
dernier point chaud de cette région du
monde israël avec un regain de tension
cisjordanie ya en effet les israéliens
ont décidé de lancer un nouveau
programme de colonies de peuplement dans
les territoires occupés mais aussi
d'arrêter le maire de naplouse la plus
grandes villes palestiniennes de
cisjordanie
le maire de naples aux bassam xhaka
dispose de 72 heures pour faire appel de
la décision d'expulsion qui lui a été
signifié avant son incarcération à la
prison de râble en signe de protestation
les autres maires des principales villes
de cisjordanie ont pour la plupart
menacé de démissionner si monsieur xhaka
n'étaient pas libérés le maire de
naplouse considéré comme favorable à
l'organisation de libération de la
palestine est accusé par les israéliens
d'avoir tenu des propos
justifiant le terrorisme et notamment
l'attentât qui avait fait 34 morts et 72
blessés sur l'autoroute tel aviv haifa
en mars 70 aujourd'hui la cour suprême
israélienne a rejeté une demande de mise
en liberté provisoire
une dernière démarche a été faite par
les maires de cisjordanie auprès du
ministre israélien de la défense
monsieur iceman pour lui demander de
libérer monsieur chat car mais monsieur
weissmann généralement considéré comme
une colombe n'a toujours pas répondu
quant à l'ol paie paradoxalement elle a
fait savoir qu'elle était opposée à la
démission collective des maires de
cisjordanie
la cisjordanie où depuis dimanche la
tension ne fait que monter une affaire
française maintenant avec tout d'abord
cette grave méprise policière orient
samedi soir un ordinateur mal informé un
policier bien nerveux une suite de
hasards malheureux résultats un jeune
homme de 20 ans à l'hôpital ce soir avec
une balle dans le cou un pompiste
s'étaient étonnés d'un chèque qui lui
remettait le conducteur d'une 504
blanche un conducteur peut être un peu
trop jeune pour une si belle voiture
mais qui peut juger les policiers
alertés interceptent le véhicule est
l'un d'eux incroyablement tir à bout
portant
22h30 vendredi soir une 504 ayant à son
bord trois jeunes gens s'arrêtent dans
cette station service pour prendre de
l'essence ont fait le plein et au mans
je suis arrivé au bord de la voiture ils
ont raccroché le pistolet alors je sais
pas c'était une fausse manoeuvre de leur
part quoi enfin moi j'avais vu la somme
au compteur ils m'ont fait le chèque à
l'intérieur de voitures montant du
chèque le chèque et à poney temps pas
conforme
ils sont directs pour l'intérieur pour
l'affermage héros fait le chèque et vous
n'avez pas eu une altercation on en sait
j'aurai ta ble ment fait venir au bureau
pour qui roule pour prendre parce échec
puisque c'est disaient ils disaient
qu'ils n'avaient qu'une envie n'écrivez
pas bien le français
donc moi j'ai répondu cheik ils ont
signé puis sont partis je vais essayer
partir j'ai relevé des numéros puis j'ai
téléphoné à la gendarmerie et du mil et
après ils m'ont dit que c'était une
voiture volée pour moi ça s'est arrêté
là je gardais le choc d'immatriculation
du véhicule et donc transmises à
l'ordinateur central de la préfecture de
police qui déclare première erreur
le véhicule volé les policiers on voit
alors un message capté par la brigade de
police spéciale de nuit d'orléans
c'est ici dans la banlieue d'orléans que
trois policiers de cette brigade
intercepte la 504 des jeunes gens
arrêtés aux feux rouges
un des agents s'avance devant la 504 et
arm son pistolet en le pointant sur le
pare-brise un doigt sur la détente
le coup est alors parti atteignant le
conducteur près du nez pour le procureur
de la république et le commissaire dont
dépendent et la brigade l'erreur et
techniques l'on ne doit pas armer son
pistolet en maintenant le doigt sur la
détente
mais ni l'un ni l'autre n'ont accepté de
répondre un entretien filmé
nous n'avons pu non plus filmer la
voiture qui est gardée par la police
au-delà de ces faits quelques questions
élémentaires se pose un policier peut-il
aussi facilement utilisé son arme et le
3 par des sommations ne sont elles pas
les festayres dans des cas de ce type en
tout cas
le jeune claude françois se trouve
aujourd'hui
grièvement blessé à l'hôpital laennec à
paris sur la base d'une erreur
d'ordinateur il était présumé coupable
un policier trop pressé n'a pas cherché
à en savoir plus très vite trop vite
il a utilisé son arme aujourd'hui on est
à fond rouge après avoir fait l'essence
de véhicules dont un restait l'arrière
deux hommes sont sortis invaincus
apparaît la route étant donné qu'on est
au feu rouge est un des policiers a tiré
sur le véhicule sur le conducteur pour
soi et puis bon nous ont descendu que
transférer les marques comme ça devant
son nez ils l'ont allongé par terre sur
le trottoir et pu nous ont fouillés nous
emmener au commissariat directement mais
ils ont tiré tout de suite sans rien
vous dire aux prêts à nous dire
on n'était pas descendu véhicules encore
en est arrêtée au feu rouge et puis
après on est attendu vaguement que
c'était l'histoire du compris ce que
qu'avait téléphoner comme quoi qu'on
avait une voiture volée et qu'on avait
fait un chèque sans provision et comment
vous avez réagi vous après au
commissariat on arrive c'était dur quand
même quand c'était un touch on savait
rien du tout alors il y en avait un mais
c'est quand même drôle et vous êtes
resté au commissariat jusqu'à quelle
heure jusqu'à 3h30 4h apprennent gens
prennent dans le maniema note tout c'est
un brillant et j'avais rien contre nous
oui de précision le policier était un
habitué du stand de tir de la police à
oria et quand le pompiste disais tout à
l'heure dans le reportage ils ont
raccroché le pistolet il faisait
allusion à l'extrémité de la pompe et
non pas un pistolet en ce moment même
une rencontre au sommet entre la cgc la
cfdt cette réunion devrait en principe
aboutir à une prise de position commune
sur la durée du travail en ce début de
semaine 3 confie tiennent toujours la
une de l'actualité alstom atlantique
d'assaut et les contrôleurs aériens
chez alstom une initiative originale
aujourd'hui celle d'un
ouvriers spécialistes de strasbourg
paris qui va relier belfort la capitale
300 km en trois jours à pied pour
remettre un communiqué au siège de son
usine pouces déroule toujours
actuellement des conversations entre
l'intersyndicale et direction chez les
contrôleurs aériens journée très dure
très peu de vols aujourd'hui 11 heures
d'arrêt ce qui a conduit une compagnie
la tat touraine air transport à mettre
son personnel en chômage technique
laurence graff et on peut se demander
pourquoi tant de dureté dans ces
conflits alors ce qui les caractérise en
tout cas c'est qu'ils sont l'on vous
voyez cette semaine chez alstom chez
rhône poulenc trois semaines pour des
sots bientôt deux semaines pour les
contrôleurs aériens
et pourtant en france en général les
grèves sont courtes si bien qu'en
interne de journées perdues pour fait
grève
la france se classe à un niveau très
moyen parmi les autres pays elle est
loin derrière le canada les états-unis
la grande-bretagne l'italie
donc c'est inhabituel et pourtant ça se
passe un période de chômage de crise
alors on peut dire que ce contexte
difficile il freine quelque soit les
conflits il peut aussi les rendre plus
dure et ce qui se passe actuellement je
crois que c'est une poussière
vindicative plus forte que qu'à
l'automne quand septembre au sommet on
al impression que l'accord cgt cfdt ne
fonctionnait pas tellement bien oui il
fonctionne quand même puisque demain par
exemple il ya une journée d'action
commune sur la durée du travail mais
c'est vrai qu'il fonctionne
difficilement premièrement pour des
raisons politiques ou avec la cfdt
accusent la cgt de coller aux pc la cgt
elle elle s'en défend et old vic c'est
la cfdt qui veut saboter l'unité
d'action et il est aussi d'autres
raisons qui tiennent par exemple aux
sélections conseil de prud'hommes alors
là il faut que vous nous expliquer en
quoi lire un rapport donc avec ces
élections prud'homales oui bon les
élections prud'homales il s'agit d'élire
des juges représentant les salariés et
les employeurs et ses juges sont
chargées de juger les conflits
individuels dans les entreprises alors
s'intéressent les syndicats parce qu'ils
présentent des listes est un des aspects
de ces élections c'est qu'elles vont
pouvoir montrer la représentativité
respectifs de chaque syndicat pour
l'instant on dispose d'assez peu de
tests dans ce domaine ya les comités
d'entreprise élections comme une
entreprise où cette touche seulement 3
millions de salariés alors à ces
élections de prud'hommes les plus de 13
millions d'inscrits de côté salariés
presqu'un million du côté employeurs
alors c'est énorme mais vous comprenez
que chaque syndicat vraiment est en
train de compter ses les siens et c'est
pour le mois prochain
c'est pour ma prochaine le 12 décembre
j'ajoute que l asp les techniciens cgt
cfdt ont ce matin mais qu'il est de
reprendre le travail mais demeure
attentif et peuvent déclencher à nouveau
un mouvement à partir de vendredi la
biologie à l'honneur ce matin les
professeurs gros jacob royer ont remis
leur rapport au président la république
ce soit vous savez tout de suite après
journalistes seront les invités de jean
pierre elkabbach et d'alain duhamel dans
cartes sur table au studio 101 martine
allain rognoni prévente l'importance et
l'enjeu du débat
oui nous voulons savoir quelle société
2000 nous prépare les biologistes et
j'ai entre les mains le fruit de
réflexions des trois personnes qui sont
derrière vous et sur un rapport qui
s'appelle sciences de la vie et société
le fruit de leurs réflexions dans
méditation et aussi de leurs
propositions
en fait beaucoup pour beaucoup d'entre
nous la biologie c'est un peu une
science naturelle que l'on apprend quand
on est petit qu'on oublie et puis on la
confie à quelques-uns 11 ans n'occupe
plus en fait nous faisons de la biologie
sans le savoir et nous devons de plus en
plus le savoir parce que nous ne pouvons
pas vivre longtemps comme maintenant
parce que nous voulons triompher de
toutes les maladies pouvoir nourrir
comme nous voulons nous reproduire comme
nous voulons la biologie c'est
effectivement l'étude de la naissance du
développement de la vie du
vieillissement de la mort la biologie
c'est le prélude aux nouveaux
médicaments aux nouveaux traitements
c'est la compréhension de l'hérédité est
aujourd'hui le début de sa manipulation
pour reprendre un terme que les
chercheurs n'aime pas beaucoup c'est le
début de la domestication des microbes
et utile c'est le début du meilleur et
parfois on craint le pire c'est la
possibilité de trouver de nouveaux
aliments de nouvelles énergies et aussi
de nouveaux comportements dans les 20
ans qui viennent on nous annonce de
nouveaux moyens de nouveaux pouvoirs de
nouveau devoir c'est de tout ceci qu'il
sera question ce soir en exclusivité sur
antenne 2 aujourd'hui d'après ce journal
à 20h35 catastrophe sans précédent au
canada deux cent quarante mille
personnes évacuées à la suite d'un
accident ferroviaire
dans la nuit de samedi à dimanche un
train qui transportait d'importantes
quantités de produits chimiques a
déraillé
les vagues ont pris feu et les autorités
craignent maintenant que les émanations
toxiques la population samedi minuit
banlieue industrielle de toronto un
essieu de wagons casse dans un train de
marchandises 25 wagons des rails des
citernes de gaz liquide et produits
chimiques dangereux et parfois mortels
incendies explosions successives de
plusieurs wagons chaque fois la boule de
feu se doit de l'autre côté du lac
ontario à 50 kg
très vite des vapeurs toxiques
envahissent les quartiers proches des
voix les habitants se plaignent aussi
sot de violentes nausées et de troubles
aux yeux panique générale
des centaines d'auto stoppeurs et des
milliers de voitures encombrent le tour
de toronto alors les sorteurs organise
une gigantesque navettes de bus et
d'ambulances où l'avait vu pour évacuer
vers les centres scolaires et sportives
de toronto les 240 milles occupants des
quartiers touchés tandis que 700
policiers y patrouille
pour éviter les pillages actuellement
les émanations se multiplient et dans
l'immédiat une angoisse terrible deux
wagons chauffés à blanc dont un de 90
tonnes de chlore son explosion menace
même toronto à quelques kilomètres
seulement du drame
coïncidence aux états unis dans le
michigan un train qui transportait des
produits chimiques a également a
déraillé mille familles ont dû être
évacuées
à l'instant une dernière dépêche en
matière sociale situation bloquée alstom
atlantique après cinq heures de
discussions donc la réunion
d'aujourd'hui n'a servi à rien
la diapositive qui précédait destiné à
vous annoncer que léopold sédar senghor
a été aujourd'hui nommé docteur honoris
causa de l'université de nancy
la cep cérémonie étaient présents le
ministre des universités alice saunier
séité qui a fait l'éloge du présent
sénégal en lui disant vous êtes le
chantre de la négritude répondu présent
sans gore en 79 notre maladie n'est ni
matériel ni biologique elle est
spirituelle
la faim dans le monde d'un sujet qui
bouleverse le pack comme tous les autres
responsables du monde
jean paul ii a rendu hommage aujourd'hui
à la haye sao l'organisation mondiale de
l'alimentation il a même à cette
occasion par les français voudraient un
petit peu de mal à reconnaître ton de
bois je vous laisse entendre quand même
si comme j de la déclaration universelle
des droits de l'homme tout en conservant
dans son action l'autonomie propre à
coudre organisation salter
gouvernementale
votre conjoint nisation a une vocation
universelle puisque elle est ouverte à
l'adhésion et tous les peuples
ce pacte qui leur était donc à
l'organisation mondiale de
l'alimentation
restons vatican si vous étiez devant
votre récepteur à 12h45 pour antenne
2010 vous avez été les premiers à voir
les fameux trésors cachés du vatican
c'est en effet la première fois qu'une
caméra pénètre dans cette très moderne
et très catholique caverne d'ali baba
alors je vous propose de suivre un
nouveau les guides quittant rarement le
père alfonso en aurait des choses à
raconter
il a participé à cinq conclave à côté
des cardinaux mais le père alfonso ne
dira rien s'il n'était pas discrets
comme un confesseur il ne serait pas
gardien du trésor du vatican
le public n'est pas admis ici il faut
une autorisation spéciale le père a fait
visiter le trésor à la reine juliana de
hollande à elizabeth taylor et à
l'écrivain roger peyrefitte qui par la
suite a écrit 2,6 vilaines choses sur le
vatican
ce crucifix or diamant et perle
c'est un cadeau de l'empereur françois
1er d'autriche au pape léon xiii
l'émeraude qui se trouve sous la croix
beau elle seule 5 millions de francs
c'est une tiare offerte par napoléon au
pape qui est venu le couronner empereur
à paris
témoignages d'affection et de respect du
roi d'espagne
ces deux calice et cette sonnette en or
massif cet anneau qui porte une robe
c'est celui de jean xxiii
je crois que vous n'aimez pas
l'expression trésors du vatican
non c'est plutôt une sacristie qu'un
trésor parce qu'il y avait ici des
objets qu'on utilise encore pour les
messes que le pape célèbre l'extérieur
du vatican le trésor est plus important
que celui de la couronne d'angleterre
je n'ai jamais vu le trésor anglais mais
d'après ce que j'ai entendu dire le
nôtre est plus importante
une tiare fabuleuse offerte par isabelle
d'espagne au pape grégoire 16 perles
émeraudes et diamants
m
e
des romains pauvres ont offert 7/3 un
pape
ce n'est pas de l'or ce ne sont pas des
diamants ou des rubis c'est du papier
argenté et doré pour emballer du
chocolat les voleurs n'ont jamais essayé
d'entrer ici n'ont jamais ils n'ont même
pas essayé le trésor est gardée par des
religieux alors il paraît que le vatican
des problèmes financiers
est-ce qu'on ne pourrait pas vendre ce
trésor laissons tomber
le trésor du vatican n'est pas à vendre
c'est un patrimoine
il y à 500 diamants incrustés dans ce
cas lice mais il me contribueront jamais
à redresser la situation financière du
vatican
c'est une question de principe quand on
parle de la richesse du vatican il faut
éviter de confondre ce qui brille et ce
qu'ils rapportent
comme dit ce religieux laissons tomber
sport la france doit vous le savez
rencontrer la tchécoslovaquie samedi
pour le championnat d'europe des nations
voici donc la liste des présélectionnés
aujourd'hui par michel hidalgo
vous voyez on découvre qu'il y a dans
cette équipe beaucoup de monégasques
plus qu'à l'habitude 4 il ya également
cinq nantais trois strasbourgeois deux
stéphanois et un médecin
un bordelais un petit peu isolé
peut-être retransmis par antenne 2 mais
rien n'est sûr la météo maintenant il a
fait un temps pluvieux des ardennes aux
vosges et des halles pour massif central
il a neigé au dessus de 600 m et un
record de froid a été battu aujourd'hui
dans le doubs il a fait moins 12 degrés
demain et bien la zone pluvieuse situer
le matin des pyrénées au massif central
et des alpes et du jura gagnera les
régions méditerranéennes sur le reste de
la france le ciel sera dit-on
généralement nuageux dès brume ou de
brouillard feront leur apparition dans
les régions de l'intérieur et les
températures seront quand même
généralement peu élevé avant de terminer
tout à fait ce journal une information
quelque peu surprenante 4e veut ni ses
fameuses objets non identifiés ont
obligé une caravelle qui volaient au
dessus de palma de majorque atterrir à
valence selon le pilote de cet appareil
quatre objets lumineux ont commencé à le
suivre il a fallu quatre avions
militaires pour que les ovnis
disparaissent une enquête est ouverte
pour le moment et puis je vous rappelle
la principale information de ce journal
qui nous est arrivé
non pas encore jean pierre elkabbach
mais d'abord cette information qui nous
est arrivé pendant le journal ou à
quelques minutes du journal le président
jimmy carter
à confirmer dans un discours qu'il avait
ordonné la réduction et même la
suspension des importations de pétrole
en provenance d'iran qu'il a même ajouté
que des consultations étaient en cours
avec ses alliés pour eva évoqué
d'éventuelles mesures de rétorsion
vous le saviez ne manquez pas cartes sur
table juste après ce journal consacré à
la biologie et à ses applications les
informations toutes dernières minutes
sous seront présentés vers 23h30 par
pierre-alain bonsoir à tout ça demain
du québec